thank you for joining us from Erica in
the lobby of Ramsey solutions Bryan and
Emily are here hey guys how are ya hi
dad welcome welcome where do you guys
live Des Moines Iowa fun well good to
have you yep appreciate you coming all
the way to Nashville and you're here to
do your debt-free scream yes we are
that's fun how much have you paid off
we paid off about fifty four thousand
eight hundred and odd dollars love it
and how long did that take you
twelve months twelve months very good
making what kind of range during that
time well we started out at ninety
thousand dollars and we jumped up to 105
thousand excellent what do you two do
for a living
I am self-employed hairstylist and then
during that time I was a programmer but
I actually just got a promotion to an
analyst position oh very cool good for
you guys
excellent so that's a ton of debt to pay
off in 12 months
did you sell something we sold our van
uh what did the van stop for $16,000
okay that makes the numbers more or I
can eat work I just was worried about
you eating there for a minute
alright you saw anything else big stuff
around the house okay garage sales yep
and you've lived on nothing yes pretty
much I mean no I mean like your friends
are making fun of you nothing like your
family thinks you need counseling
nothing yeah beans and rice rice and
beans here a lot of meal planning very
good good job you guys
so something got you guys some just lit
you on fire twelve months ago what
happened it's a lot of things that
happen in 2014 we've been trying to have
children for about four or five years
and we were able to so we felt led to
become foster parents cool and so in the
beginning of 2014 we got our first
placement a three-month-old boy
his name's Denver and that kind of
started our whole journey through the
rest of the year we've we got the
opportunity to adopt him oh wow in June
yeah it was super exciting
however the day of the
the adoption trial I actually had to
have surgery because I was cleaning the
gutters and fell off the ladder and
broke my arm oh good so then I had to
have surgery and I was out of work for
the month that was kind of a right and
so costly gutter cleaning yes yes and we
actually end up financing new gutters
too after that worth to do but then the
rest of the fall in summer I was having
a lot of issues with my arm and it turns
out my bone wasn't growing back in my
arm
ooh and so we tried different therapies
and stuff and at the end of October they
basically said it's not gonna grow back
we have to have another surgery so they
went in and took bone from my leg Oh fun
put it into my arm and we had surgery
two weeks after that appointment in the
very very beginning of November yeah and
so then I was out of work from November
all the way through December we only had
short-term disability
Emily's self-employed she's taking care
of our son she our just y'all were just
getting the crud beat out of you and
then a week after he had his second
surgery in November we found out we were
pregnant and then three days later we
found out that we were mr. Carey oh and
I miscarried on Thanksgiving mm-hm so it
was just really like the hardest year of
our whole life sounds like we're just
sick and tired of the second time beaten
down and we just felt like January or
2015 was gonna be a new beginning for us
and we wanted to do things the right way
this time and prepare for the next
emergency and yeah I think the moment it
clicked was I came back to work in
January and I was listening to your
podcast and you were talking about not
New Year's resolutions but goals and
setting goals in multiple areas
financially spiritually emotionally
relationship relationships and it
clicked right there I'm like this this
is it we're doing this we're saying no
to what we're doing and we're and you've
burned through hell and hell financially
in the process yet all his debt riding
you down while you were already knocked
to your knees yeah oh my god yeah
that'll get your attention
yeah yeah so that I came home we kind of
got back up and stood on the side of the
beach in the open
it's like a visceral animal scream but
Lieutenant Dan yelling at God and so I
came home to Emily I'm like hey we got
to do this and she's like yep let's do
it yeah and she was on board from the
beginning and that's that's kind of what
2015 started out and she was ready to
you know so yeah so living on nothing
was no problem after well you've been
through you're like this is a cakewalk
compared to that other year that's
nothing
some people call that sacrifice but not
after what y'all have been through the
year before Wow
it gives you perspective yes that much
pain gives you perspective yeah just
being able to walk you know I didn't get
the adoption go through yeah so we had a
reschedule sans one ladder dive but
unbelievable okay very cool you guys
will congratulations thank you after all
of that to stand here and not have a
debt in the world it's got to feel like
you've lost 300 pounds totally anything
bring it oh you got bring it yeah you
guys you're tough that tough and jump it
really does very cool how long have you
been married we've been married oby nine
years this summer okay yeah so you were
getting all of this at about the
seven-year mark yes yeah which is always
a not a good mark not always but
sometimes not good
Wow amazing well congratulations I'm
very proud of you
thank you I mean you persevered yeah and
so when people hear that you paid off
fifty five thousand and twelve months
you sold your van to do it among other
things and they asked how did you do
that what do you tell them the secrets
are well first of all the budget having
him plan meal planning was a huge thing
for me and just having a plan for every
area of your life
because it controls every area I'd also
say teamwork like bringing it together
like 2015 was still a really hard year
for us Ryan had a second job and during
that time we actually got a newborn baby
through the foster care system for three
months and we had water in our basement
like a half inch of water through a
whole nother hard year and we still
stuck to it just really just sticking to
the plan so your guns
following if you got a system and it's
working it's easier to stick to it when
there's don't when the rain comes you
know when the storm comes in this case
when the water comes literally you know
unbelievable so Brian what do you tell
people the secret is budgeting was a big
thing for us we tried it way back in the
days and I tried it my own way just it
didn't work and so sticking to the
budget doing it together in
communicating I'm definitely the nerd
obviously I spent four hours creating
the first spreadsheet when we first
started to this packaging so getting
Emily in on that and communicating and
agreeing to it that that was the key for
us I feel like wow very cool well I'm
proud of you guys
I'm really proud of you think very very
well done and what a story I mean you
have persevered and you scratched and
clawed all the way through all right
it's Brian and Emily from Des Moines
Iowa $55,000 paid off in 12 months
making ninety two hundred and five count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
I love it very well done you two very
well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind